the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video all right my
friends in this video i will be
delivering some of the most exciting
news we have heard regarding house of
the dragon thus far
now as you all know hbo is developing
another game of thrones series set in
george rr martin's a song of ice and
fire universe in house of the dragon we
will finally see what happened to house
targaryen during the dance of dragons
when this family nearly drove itself
into early extinction
these events happened roughly 170 years
before the events in game of thrones
now although the dance of dragons did
not happen during the main series house
of the dragon will still have all of
those same familiar ingredients from
game of thrones that we all know and
love
yesterday on george rr martin's not a
blog website he gave us a new update
about house of the dragon
what he said has me very excited because
he not only admitted that he had seen
the first episode of house of the dragon
but he has also said that he loves it
and he thinks all of us will love it as
well now let me show you what he said
on his not a blog website george rr
martin said the new year is almost at
hand and with it will come all the
manner of new television shows on
network cable and streamers i have got
to confess i was just to read that the
most anticipated new show according to
imdb was house of the dragon it is one
hell of a list to be at the top of too
amazon's new lord of the rings series
neil gaiman sandman marvel shows star
wars shows house of the dragon is at the
very top of this list right now that's
good company i am anticipating house of
the dragon pretty eagerly myself for
what it's worth okay i am hardly
objective and i know a lot of what you
will be seeing
i um wrote the book also mum's the word
now don't tell anyone i've seen a rough
cut of the first episode and i loved it
it's dark it's powerful it's visceral
just the way i like my epic fantasy ryan
and miguel have done an amazing job and
the cast just as with game of thrones
most viewers will only have heard of a
few of the actors but i think you're
gonna fall in love with a lot of them
only to then have your heart breaking
later on but no that would be telling i
think the targaryens are in very good
hands anticipate away i do not think you
will be disappointed
well my friends there you have it from
the horse's very own mouth
this is by far the greatest update
regarding house of the dragon that i
have seen all week if george rr martin
actually loves it as much as he says he
does hopefully that means we will as
well
as you can see he did say it's exactly
how he likes his epic fantasy so let's
all hope that it has that early game of
thrones feel like the series did during
the first four seasons when i think
almost everyone can agree when the show
was at its best maybe this also means we
will be getting an official trailer soon
i know i'm not the only one looking
forward to that now if you have seen a
lot of my other house of the dragon
videos this update shouldn't come as a
big surprise because we already knew
ryan and miguel were the right ones for
the job as i'm sure most of you know by
now miguel sapochnick is famously known
for directing some of game of thrones
greatest episodes like hard home battle
of the bastards and the winds of winter
not only is he one of the showrunners on
house of the dragon but if i remember
correctly he will be directing some of
the episodes as well i do believe he
directed this first episode now ryan
condole is the other showrunner
alongside miguel as well as the show's
co-creator if you heard his interview
with george rr martin then you know he
knows the universe inside and out in
fact it's one of the main reasons george
rr martin wanted him working on house of
the dragon he knew ryan had already read
a song of ice and fire we had done an uh
a round of development
if you go back
when it was clear that the game of
thrones was ending that dave and dan
wanted to end it after seven seasons or
something
hbo started looking to develop other
other shows
and um
the two that i pitched were dancing with
a dragon which became
uh house of dragon and uh
the dunkin egg thing
but there were a number of other shows
that were developed at that time
most of them put together by writers
that hbo hired
uh
who had never read my books
and who i guess had watched the show and
they were doing and when we were getting
into this i didn't want that anymore
obviously none of those shows ultimately
got on the air i thought you know i want
people if they're going to be working in
my world i want them to actually have
read my books and i liked ryan's work
and i knew he knew the world he had read
the books so
once again in that bar at the four
seasons uh yeah where it all uh started
there
ryan has even stated that he learned a
lot about writing from reading a song of
ice and fire where dan and dave might
have been fans of a song of ice and fire
it actually sounds like ryan is a
student of a song of ice and fire so i
think the show is in great hands as well
tell me about how you guys met a little
bit because i think our audience would
actually really enjoy this i'm a super
fan and i i found the books
at this point over 20 years ago
and uh i loved them i was a huge uh
tolkien fan lord of the rings just that
you know worshiped at the at the at the
altar of it the movies were coming out
and i had i just reread them and i was
in this kind of fantasy mode and i was
like what else is out there and a friend
had recommended hey if you love tolkien
you should really check this out because
it's it's really the only it's the it's
the it's the only thing since tolkien
that really got me up out of my seat
fantasy-wise i've liked other fantasies
i've enjoyed things
there's some great classic books out
there but
nothing to me held the candle to to
tolkien but this did and it was of
course the first book game of thrones
and i read and i just i fell all the way
in i was all in like you know i i
couldn't believe how good it was i i
read all three there were three books at
the time storm swords that just had just
been published and i just devoured them
and then went back and devoured them
again and i and it just it became my
favorite thing so and this happened at a
time where i was learning to to write
myself uh i was very interested in
screenwriting i'd written a couple of
scripts i was starting to try to make a
career of this i was in my early 20s and
um you know cut to a number of years
later i'm not i've now broken in i still
love these books i'm a huge fan of the
television show i'm watching it all i
tried to get at some point i tried to
get my agents to get me a staff writer
job on the show and they were like they
don't have staff writers it's just the
two of them write the whole show
so um i respected him so much and
actually learned so much from him as a
writer because i i mean i credit even
though the
the books are prose books george started
as a dramatic writer a screenwriter
intelligence the books are written in
this
dave you've read them they're written in
this incredibly cinematic way with hooks
at the end of chapters there's dialogue
i mean it's written you could very
easily just put slug lines into those
books and create scenes out of them it's
not a novelistic style of writing so i
learned a lot about character and
storytelling and atmosphere and theme
and all these you know
literary tools like you know
foreshadowing and how to you know how to
write prophecy compelling prophecy that
doesn't seem you know uh
dinky or foregone conclusion all these
things that i i still use today that i
learned from those books so it was just
really exciting for me to be able to
meet george and then we and then we hit
it off and then you know on down the
road we go you know some you know five
six seven years later turned into a job
offer which still i mean as still it
still
blows my mind that i'm that i'm sitting
here doing this show
all of this has me very excited for
house of the dragon now like i say in a
lot of my other videos make sure all of
you subscribe now that way you can get
notified whenever i drop a new video
that way you can stay in the know and up
to date on any and all information
regarding game of thrones house of the
dragon and a song of ice and fire
the amount of videos i will be making
will only increase now that house of the
dragon is finally here
as always i want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching this video i
hope all of you have a great day i will
see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you